what about acting can that be a
part-time thing I know a few people that
have told me you know I love to act but
it's so difficult that I just don't want
to keep going out on these auditions so
if I can do a couple things a year I'm
totally fine you know if it depends on
what your your level of comfort is if
that's okay
and you don't have to putting food on
your table and paying your rent doesn't
have to depend on acting then sure you
can you can treat it as a hobby you can
do theater you can sort of pick and
choose what's available at that level at
the hobby level you have to remember
again that this is Los Angeles and it's
the I I like to think it's still the the
center of the entertainment business
there's a lot of competition here there
are if you're thinking of acting believe
me there are people that have been doing
it far longer than you have and that
have resumes as long as your arm who
maybe 12 years old so that's what your
that's what your face to it that's the
kind of competition you're faced with
here but again if if you want to pursue
it as as some vocation as an occupation
then you're gonna have to do it
full-time yeah and you just jump in you
just jump in and you develop that resume
and you develop the the kind of presence
that is attractive to casting offices
and and into agents to get yourself some
repute representation and sure it's open
to everybody and they're you know there
are the stories of overnight successes
but I don't know of anybody who has been
one of those Lana Turner and the coffee
shop yeah yeah but there's something
with actors that pulls us into this it's
not that it's not that we want to do
this necessarily oh is this a choice
that I would have made not really from
the time I was a kid I just wanted to
tell stories I loved to tell stories and
I had to
I wanted to express myself in that way
and I had to do it it was much more of a
situation of feeling as if I had to do
it or I would explode then making a
conscious choice to do it
which I don't knowing what I know know
about how difficult it is I don't think
I ever would have made that choice
I just died but I had to I had to and
here we are
you